okay that was around six of seven thanks
people thanks talkie so I'm probably
close to money I could be playing could
be playing penguin but there's a few a
few games still going
penguins still playing penguin verse GM
Verde notes we don't even need the
engine here so penguins gonna win
another game man I think prizes I
shouldn't I shouldn't really worry too
much about the prize money you just want
to play good chess but I think they go
to top four there is okay there's still
some people that can be tied with me so
I don't think I'll play penguin Loess oh
there's no four and a half
I could play penguin I'm play penguin
black he's playing in London or just
Queen's Gambit hmm okay it'll be
interesting though v gets 100 oh okay
my tie breaks don't appear to be so
great like a lot of people below me have
better topics sent me okay so penguin
just winning that's whose other player
oh it's a time scramble but penguins so
fast
Oh penguin so that was uh that was
Gawain Jones
so penguin got revenge for me kind of
penguin six out of six so yeah I
probably won't play penguin I'll
probably play I can't play Christopher
I'll probably play one of these two Raja
or two players from India both Iams
so draw probably I don't know I draw
probably wouldn't give me much and we'll
see that's round about to start
this is an open tournament there's
different sections though so there's a
this is a 2100 plus section various
sections I think all the way down until
II a thousand maybe oh I'm waiting again
okay goodbye chat hiding you again takis
there to to maybe keep asking questions
rather than answer questions
ah he's also there to mod but okay let's
say focus once again have a normal
London this time playing the one the
only opening he knows go rosin Oh Karen
yeah so playing some kind of mainline
this move order area will see what a
block is up to Queen c7 live Queen c7
yeah I think idea setae can play Bishop
d3 and then go for a for there's a trap
here knight c6 93 wins apiece and we are
rated for rating boom
whoa whoa it's a read from call the cops
key someone give a shout out tog II give
a shout out to call the cops key but you
have to spell his name correctly thanks
Cara if you're just joining I'm playing
serious chest so I can't really interact
too much with the chats but thanks for
the rain also I posted a YouTube video
earlier today of me and ghada's bullet
game god Gotha also a London like London
God probably knows knows these lines
better than me
he force a way to go like because box
open H file I might want a Castle
queenside and if takes there's actually
an interesting choice between bishop or
Knight takes the benefit of bishop takes
is that if black takes and I just get
initiative I guess I got initiative
another line to I kind of like Bishop
takes remember studying this this idea
and other lines might be incorrect here
I don't know because if I take with
Knight
then we trade the Knights comes to d7 it
could be similar so you Letitia
it feels very like strange like very
counterintuitive but it's some attempt
to keep black more confined and I don't
think there's so much incentive for
black to actually take the bishop
because in d6 is weak I could just be
getting lines confused but okay like
it's I think it's a comfortable position
to play for whites there's a few ideas
there's costume Queen sigh and there's
g4 g5 there's playing positionally and
black still a bit underdeveloped as
Bishop also tries to discourage blacks
Queen side development then Queen e2 is
a way to go a it's a sub thanks new Sun
this week we need to this Bishop Cena
for coming
Oh Bishop g4 hangs upon never mind okay
I really have to stay focused here
trying to evaluate like this position if
I do castle if i king's in any danger
they makes a lot of sense like open D
file attacking potential we fives also
targets knight c6 there might be some
possibility of of winning upon Eric
Rosen trying to tie for first or second
or something so trying is the first tip
to failure yes it's another opening I I
really can't complain about I got a
position that's comfortable with a
slight time advantage late c6 is very
natural
okay so lock does take yeah so the two
knights I think work well together
the Queen's attacks so the Queen has to
move probably still tied down to the
pawn as well Queen here I might have
this move because tactics morale stills
the Queen go Queenie five or Queenie
seven yeah so Bishop g4 coming I mean
Queens like castling I want to play you
want to play 96 some points in Bishop e6
maybe I went upon
yeah relying on some intuition
there's always king b1 always play king
b1
okay so 96 doesn't move blocks kind of
consolidating though in 96 he says rook
t8 I don't have g4 g5
it's Queen III I'm King bee one might be
the move to play here
there's Bishop f5 I wanted to play
Queenie 395 oh there's a cool idea -
there's some some prospect of actually
sacking because there's a knight f6 and
rook h1 I'd have to of course calculate
but it's interesting Bishop f5 yeah I
don't think stacking works 96 looks
appealing calm is my king kinda gets cut
off to do so this is another idea 9h for
to play d4 Knight a5
I don't know why I'm still drawn to rook
h6 I kind of like night night each for
each word Bishop Miege 7g for my comes
to have five this was Queen e6
then there's g5 ideas - it could get
very sharp looking at lines where black
takes honey - and then I go all out for
some attack but I want to I do want to
play g4 so I guess this is kind of an
expected line g4 Queen e6
I guess 9f5 neither v they're sacking
I'm not acting either pawn so if if
flock takes this way Queen a for some
some move I was hoping I get some
compensation there
it's hard I just see what to do some g3
move yeah the bishop found a good square
thanks for subbing okay so I'm trying to
find compensation in this line because I
think other lines do work take six takes
let's still the prospect of G 4 and G 4G
5g there's 96 on that line to line 96
it's a queen and the pawn when the four
we got some endgame yeah okay it's very
risky there's also g5 immediately it's
not what I was expecting maybe if one
interest in consider Queenie 625 check
but okay the Knights prospects for
Knight a5 are promising knife f5 and the
combination of the open each file g5
ideas still have to be careful always
play King be one man always play King be
19.95 five I'm fine golden I hope you're
proud of me Eric Rosen good f3 maybe
coming okay so we're just training I win
upon maybe not quite winning upon
oh it's very tricky
how time is relevant to to take take oh
I forgot about that should've seen that
okay so now probably can see to
preventing Queen d2 time is not good
positions still fine the black bloc's
not in danger of getting mated
unfortunately Queen c7 Zamu Queen c7
could be threatening some night check
but probably not
I was very hard to remove this night
because g6 those h6k h7 never possible
f6 is probably weakening I'm just not
sure how I make progress but black is
also like we're both kind of it's hard
for both of us to actually find
productive moves that's a probably good
move so I have Knights and 93 can be
safe
how's it aimed too much Queeny Queeny
six could be a problem so I might want
to trade actually actually Queen a six I
do you have Queen c4 26 turns us and
this the Queen c4 defines everything
it's tied down yeah then the knight on
c6 is not a great piece but it has to
stay there I have to be careful like
Queen c5 then Queen D five runs in
tonight before places smooth before
actually looks interesting
just again more restricting the nights
it kind of exposes a king but now
there's lingering ideas of b5 so we
might see a six a six maybe a four just
a natural follow-up Queen h4 I was also
considering I think we need to work to
me met with Queen a5 yeah so this is a
requirement of time the King might find
a safe place on b3
very tricky position Queen night endings
are are very very tricky hmm I throw in
g3 let's try this some threat of doing
things with Queen c8
I would love to play Queen Daisy seven
out of five but not quite legal
so I'm calculating g6 or nevermind
probably good move so let's play this
hitting the pawn but my queen side down
to f/2
okay so we have a two-way tie for first
and if Rosen wins or Roger wins they tie
for first
so if you a two or three way tie for
fourth tricky position still feeling
good the g3 queen h2 not sure what to do
about that I probably want to play a
five actually a fives very nice
positional you for long before Queen
Queen each three your queen up for maybe
Queen a for some Chuck yeah there's
Queen a five here
we could repeat 90 sudden queen up for a
while
I don't want to draw though so how to
deviate I'm taking on e4 and takes on e4
Queen b3 their King yeah so it takes on
you for Queen off to king b3 it's shaky
when g3 looks grotesque so I should look
at the standings because this is
actually relevant
give me five and a half I mean I don't
want triple pawns but maybe I do
it also Queen B - no Queen B eights Oh
Queen B H III don't think that works
look a little bit longer queen v8 queen
bee a g3 everything's too risky
my times yeah we'll see maybe my
opponent wants to play on to try and
play for time that's the one possibility
for me if I get the chance okay King b3
would be useful if I will be useful I
have to play Queen f4 I mean there's no
other move I don't think okay well
that's my tournaments I don't know it
was like better there are some really
interesting lines but it's one of those
things that's so risky with with time
and I finish out of top five because
yeah I probably should have played on
four or something but I didn't see it I
didn't see it I'm sure computer a
computer will find maybe something
where's the game oh I have to analyze
first no so how does this work Queen uh
597 so Queen takes e4 yeah I just didn't
want to leave myself at these pawns I'm
King yeah King g3 so unnatural and yeah
King I mean King bee 396 it seems like
black consolidates so I don't know how
real this +1 is maybe I mean if I had
like 30 more minutes know how this makes
any sense to put the King here
it's the only way to keep plus-one yeah
we take c4 yeah okay I'm not too
disappointed so I didn't mess anything
like so obvious but yeah that was a fun
tournament
I didn't finish within the money
unfortunately I assume because tiebreaks
oh actually no but Christopher you Wow
so I was the only player to be
Christopher you but then he he won the
rest of his games so he caught up I
didn't win money
oh maybe I I won bits from Texas time
says great fun to watch thank you well
thank you Texas time for all the bits so
I'll probably know people are telling me
I want money but I don't know if there
is or tiebreaks not used so maybe I owe
is there a media Oh Ben just said that
on stream hey I won money so yeah I
think I guess it's different like in
European events they use they they don't
really split prize if you tie for
something they do use tie breaks but in
u.s. US events they they do split a few
tie for something so I guess there is a
four-way tie for third nice how much
money is that mayhem so we have to do
math four-way tie for third that's like
$100 probably a little bit more than
hundred dollars Oh prizes for top five
oh maybe they they probably change this
because there are more sponsors nice
yeah that was a fun event it is actually
kind of refreshing to play not bullet or
even blitz but to play like longer chess
to have time to think I think that
quality was pretty decent
well thanks so much heart wise a noodle
for 1,500 bits
yeah I'll probably put the whole thing
on YouTube I don't know if I'll probably
won't need to do much editing at all
because uh the priests were relatively
quick for me a lot of a lot of long
games was expecting longer breaks but my
games just these most of them seem to go
to the very end so yeah if you're
watching in the future on YouTube thanks
for watching leave a like leave a
comment subscribe it really does
actually help the YouTube algorithm so I
do appreciate when people do that and
stay tuned for more more content